si je vous ai sorti
un exemplaire de ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler le cadastre napoléonien donc
le premier cadastre qui étaient
élaborées dans le premier tiers du 19e
siècle
un atlas qui détaille chaque commune du
département un document d'habitude
consultable sur internet
mais pour leur nouvelle édition de
faites de l'histoire les archives
départementales le feront découvrir au
public
nous proposerons notamment à l'occasion
de cette journée du 23 un atelier qui
permettra aux personnes de se
familiariser à la recherche pour faire
l'historique de sa maison quelles sont
les ressources que l'on peut consulter
quelles sont les ressources disponibles
chez nous est ce qu'elles sont
consultables en ligne
faire l'histoire de sa maison à travers
les âges cette année les archives
s'intéresse à l'urbanisme et au lieu de
vie fait on voit au niveau de la rue où
est installée la cité des dents de scie
que les habitants sont quasiment pour la
plupart des employés de chemin de fer
les trois uniques qui seront proposées
ce jour là
eh bien ce sera la visite du quartier la
sourderie le quartier des dents de scie
et une thématique sur la reno a 50 ans
jeu de piste contes pour les enfants ou
encore oeuvre collaborative les archives
départementales se sont associés pour
cette journée au musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines